and finally new rule you don't really
love America if you hate half the people
in it
and also if you hate a lot of the things
that everybody always loved about it
there's an off repeated moment in
political debates where the moderator
says to the two candidates say something
nice about your opponent can you uh say
one nice thing something that you admire
about your opponent and say something
nice about representative deal tell us
something that you and I are about your
opponent can you say something nice
about your opponent
[Applause]
it's always so awkward because the
candidates just spent an hour describing
how America would be an out of control
dumpster fire if the other guy won the
election
but they still try to answer it
I respect his children
I commend him for what he's doing around
cats he was he was a scout
it's terrific
that you are
a very well dressed
you have a very good golf game
those two little boys they are so cute
okay I say the next time we have debates
the moderator needs to frame that
question a little differently as say
something about America that you like
because honestly I don't know why the
people who are fighting for this country
so hard even want it anymore Republicans
I'll start with you I really want to
know what do you like about America it's
not democracy
you stand with the president who tried
to pull off a coup and a dozen
republican nominees for Senate and
governor in this year's midterms say
they absolutely will not commit to
accepting the results elections only
count when we win them that's what
America is to you now I chose more
disrespect for the flag than any
football player ever could
Utah Senator Mike Lee says outright
we're not a democracy no not the way you
want to run things
this year at least 27 states have
introduced or enacted laws that restrict
voting if you say you love America don't
you also have to love the idea of
everyone getting to vote don't you have
to love the peaceful transfer of power
Republican
Republicans remind me of the Trophy
Hunters who say they love Wildlife yeah
then why do you shoot it
foreign
Republicans used to be the rule of law
people and lionized the officers who
upheld it but when rioters stormed the
Citadel and symbol of America on January
6th most Republicans took their side and
not the side of the police over a
hundred of whom were wounded [ __ ] the
police that is the Clarion call of the
Republican party now
when did the GOP become NWA
uh and then there's the uh the FBI Steve
Bannon says that the Gestapo Marjorie
Taylor green says they should be
defunded Congressman Paul gosar says we
must destroy the FBI what the FBI is not
American now
FBI agents are so Square they yell four
when they ejaculate
they think matching windbreakers are
cool
foreign
s have flag pins
[Applause]
and the military it used to be in the
same category the Bedrock of the super
Patriot crowd but Trump began his first
campaign by doing something that up till
then was Unthinkable he mocked and
derided a war hero a republican war hero
who had been shot down imprisoned and
tortured and it was not a bridge too far
for Republicans they Shrugged and walked
across it as they did when Trump called
The Joint Chiefs loses
and our soldiers who died in World War
One losers Ted Cruz calls today's troops
pansies and Republican Senate nominee
Blake Masters says our generals are
left-wing corporate bozos that's the
Patriotic view of our military breath
maybe that's why Trump said he wished
they acted more like the Nazi generals
we fought in World War II
yeah we won that one by the way
so
I ask again if you don't like democracy
voting the FBI the military and cops
what about America do you like
oh I know the Constitution that's right
the grand old oh what's that Congressman
Lauren bobert says what
she says I'm tired of this separation of
church and state junk that's not in the
Constitution
but it is in the Constitution and it's
another one of those pillars of this
country that if you don't believe in it
it makes me wonder why you're fighting
so hard for this place at all
and that
and that's that is what's so odd about
this time that we're living in for all
the talk about fighting for the soul of
America nobody seems to like it very
much
too many liberals give the impression
that to them America is just a big
the red white and ooh
[Music]
a country that started out bad and will
always be bad founded on an unrelenting
history of sucking
and unable to change but we have changed
a lot
Democrat Corey Bush tweeted This Land Is
Stolen land and black people still
aren't free and this was on the 4th of
July really not that I give a [ __ ] about
the Fourth of July I've never been a
rah-rah guy
but I am a prospective guy
and that's what too much of the left has
lost perspective 72 percent of black
people under 30 are optimistic about
their future in America way more than
white people the same age
and as far as the land goes yes I guess
we could change the name of Captain
America to Captain stolen land
[Applause]
but honestly to all the people who start
every public event now with one of those
land acknowledgments where they say I'm
standing on land that was stolen from
the proud indigenous people of the
Chumash tribe I say either give it back
or shut the [ __ ] up
[Applause]
AOC says so many people in this country
hate women oh geez
even the guy at the party who pulls out
a guitar is like way to ruin the fun
[Laughter]
Congressman Jamal Bowman says capitalism
is slavery by another name no it's not
it's the thing that has given more
people more prosperity and hope than any
other system flawed though it surely is
but
but again something like the free market
is kind of synonymous with America and
if you don't like it I don't know how
you can say you love this country you
know who loves this country you know
who's not constantly complaining about
what happened 200 years ago and who's
not obsessed with seeing America through
shit-colored glasses and shaking off the
stench of what irredeemable privileged
[ __ ] we are immigrants
foreign
ask any of them why they came here and
they will tell you the same thing Ron
DeSantis put me on a plane
but they will also tell you that America
for all that's so shitty about it right
now is still the last best hope and
those people asking for our votes to
take it over should remember that